no you see the whole thing babe see the
whole thing I'll do the next one in my
bad news submitted by pooper scooper you
a woman was accidentally given erectile
disfunction cream for her dysfunction
Creek well she's constantly look like
she's shocked rub my eyes what happens
if a lady puts erectile disfunction
cream on her bagina you might have a
hard-ass cliff yeah and her [ __ ] will
probably be bigger than my penis aw
that's cute let me see it pull it out no
you know he likes doing that bar yeah
yeah I'm not gonna do that anymore guys
sorry you no longer showing your private
parts anymore I'm not allowed to say it
you show my penis anymore no because I'm
on a family show and they're like don't
do it
and then everyone that that works with
but they said don't do it anymore there
no it's even there but also the people
that you know my man everyone they says
don't do it anymore because I'm getting
older I'm getting older and when you
show people your penis when you're like
in your for it is yeah it gets kind of
weird oh you're just a little hard
Kellie that's all yeah as a young man
it's cool it's cute
Yeah right babe yeah
anyway yeah so this woman here she
suffered chemical injuries because she
was mistakenly prescribed
erectile-dysfunction cream she was given
a prescription for eye lubricants and
it's a vida
- pause so it's V ITA - POS that's the
name of that lubricate and so instead
she was given via truce vit a ro s how's
anybody supposed to know that well have
you seen her doctors writing maybe
that's what happened that's exactly what
happened it was the handwriting they
misread it well you know it's funny like
out of all these people in this process
no one second-guess the fact that
woman was getting erect I was just
picking it up for husband no but it's in
her name and also like the administering
what is it directions they also say like
you know to put it in your eyes so like
how did no one [ __ ] Viva the
pharmacist [ __ ] up of course yeah
pharmacist cuz I get hurt the tampons
all the time
what the fling with the wings whatever I
mean whatever they whatever this is they
stick it in there the one that they pour
the you can't stick a pad in your vagina
you can't go like this no no you roll it
in a thing you stick it in your vagina
and then you fly when I go to the Rite
Aid I don't even say tampon I go like
this
and then they show me like Bobby's back
again you do like that stick ya know
when you say I make like rosemary
what's the string for you string in
first
oh no it's like you put this in and then
you go like that ah like this one this
is the tampon right it goes in and it
stays in the vagina like that and in the
string pulls it out like oh I was doing
it wrong I was doing it wrong so you do
order you do I still have three stuck
inside
ouch you know but sometimes I've heard
stories of women I forget that they have
one in I thought I had one in there like
I still this day I feel like I have one
in there what you would know you know my
friend who that happened to and she said
for three weeks she just had a funky
smell
oh well it's going to you know we're all
this like bacteria yeah so she said she
had his like nasty like smelly discharge
you say tonight fection I mean she could
have easily she would you can also get
like toxic shock from that
yeah so eventually she's just spotted
out what is toxic shop toxic shock
syndrome is when when you stick a tampon
up there and then it recruits all this
type of bacteria usually like staph and
then it causes this like massive rack
but it also happens to I can finish our
body not necessarily go mean to be right
toxic shock me your blood is poisoned
after yeah it's like an infection that
goes into your blood and then it [ __ ]
poisons all over your body the shock
part is when your blood pressure drops
and you eventually die okay I don't have
anything in there can I ask a question
do animals get periods yes a frog a frog
gets a period
ribbit right aid oh no but if you pay
the doggies and kitties they don't
appear they don't bleed anymore
I'm gonna have my dog in underwear I see
yeah yeah because they'll bleed all over
the house yeah really
it's [ __ ] disgusting whoa I mean it's
natural it's beautiful oh yeah dog ponds
there are dog diapers though yes then oh
yeah do you teach kalila Taji you're
gonna call me Geo cuz he's been calling
me Gina this whole time but yes Gina can
you teach Coelho how to flush the toilet
when she puts the tampon in the toilet
you have another make sure of that
twice and I have it on my phone twice he
takes a picture of it you remember what
you did you showed the white [ __ ] you
yeah with my pale poo what white [ __ ]
[ __ ] white [ __ ] after like a stomach
right that's how regal [ __ ] comes out
white only her and Cate Blanchett have
white there keep Blanchett suit but she
has white hair
I heard that comes from eating a lot of
cabbage or salty burgers what you
talking about Willis all white [ __ ]
equals cabbage okay sorry why'd you guys
see your poop I can't move on he took a
picture because it was she forgot to
plush oh how do you forget the flush
exactly I mean have you never forgotten
to fly absolutely not you know don't
know as an adult no sometimes don't
really smell it doesn't have to smell it
it just it checks out from my [ __ ] so
I know it comes out
yeah confronted by the [ __ ] when you
stand up it's happened to me before
because are you on your phone are you
standing up and you don't wipe and you
walk away so I have a mirror right in
front and then the sinks right in front
so the toilets here mirrors right here
so I'm doing it and then I usually do
the get up and flush but I guess for
some reason I just really wanted to wash
maybe got [ __ ] on my fingers though yeah
I wanted to wash my hand so I wash my
hands and then I start fixing my hair I
look at my face and then by that time
then you realize your [ __ ] in your head
then you freak out oh my god did you
pick the shower yeah and then I just
walk out and then I'm like oh yeah both
of you are savages so I think what
happened was she saw it freaked out
everyone looks at their pool when they
pool I have to see of course looks like
a president or you know man
well that one looks like you know John
Adams whatever like that so what
sometimes I don't flush those but she
saw her poo
it was albino white and she probably
subconsciously said I'm not flushing it
I'm tomorrow this is special she's
showcasing her poster that I took a
photo of it and she knew I was gonna do
that you shadow diamond you should have
put in a ziploc bag and pen freezer keep
it forever I know my dogs would [ __ ]
white when they eat like bones that I
would give them were you eating boys
must be rough in the house of Bobby Lee
what is this about I forgot she got a
chemical is she blind
oxygen syndrome is the chemical injuries
see my dumb ass would have been like the
doctor prescribed it maybe this is
what's supposed to happen and you just
keep using it to the iPhone yeah oh yeah
that would be soft again we're so
spineless that we would probably just
take it until the cream was done I'm
right there with you guys
they call me into deep cuz I never speak
up for myself they say anything so that
totally would be read you she's like in
your face and it happened three years
ago when nobody's around her when she
says it
that's how late she is did this outcome
I am I brush my teeth with a foot cream
before you know brushing my teeth and I
don't even look at the thing why would
you and then I look and it's its foot
cream wash wait why is the foot goodness
you see because it's where my feet go
well my feet are there well he said it
like I was like well you bought it and
go [ __ ] yourself there i won in my face
right Jeannie
right do you need your mom I know you
see me as your mom that's sweet I [ __ ]
up on your name one time and you're
gonna use it against me for how long I
don't fancy are you still bummed by it
no cuz you call me geo twice
30-something I love you know I love you
I do I do know you know I like Billy
your husband and he's great and Tommy
and Frank I love them all you guys are
amazing you know me you to Sasha
Venezuela whatever your last name is
Sasha Venezuela Venezuela my feet oh
I've accidentally used shaving cream
whoa toothpaste Oh
Casey's toothbrush grossed me out so bad
like he wants to use my [ __ ] all the
time
NAT I do it on purpose is because I left
my downstairs and those bars dude no
questions we have on the road yeah on
the road
yaaay I'd rather not brush my best
normal you know what's weird cuz like
I'm down a shared gum with my husband
but I just freshening no that's weird
that is weird right that's it we're just
rinse if gum is nastier
cuz it's pulling the [ __ ] out for a
toothbrush but I would share Jess's
toothbrush I wouldn't share my own with
myself cuz I smell my toothbrush and
it's gross and she keeps her tooth she
keeps her toothbrush nice and smelly
doesn't smell bad
you clean her toothbrush at ease
no dude I brush my teeth in a shower and
I chuck it outside and I try to make it
land inside the sink and it doesn't land
sometimes won't you buy tooted I just
grabbed it off the floor and I leave it
there until I come back and use it again
get two toothbrushes we went outside and
the one in the shower I have two one of
the shower exactly oh damn damn it
you're you're right I do and you know
what I have more than one toothbrush
laying around - I should do that
separate bathroom so you actually have
to go to your way to go to her bathroom
to use her toothbrush no no it's on the
road like them yeah yeah so that's on
accident we also share underwear yeah we
share well how do you share underwear
what do I take it off he has a big belly
but no hips so he wears everything under
his belly tight hips so I'm [ __ ] up
here it's cuz I know I have here I had a
physical and like doctor said I have
hips
yeah well he didn't say I didn't have
them you didn't say you had exactly goes
oh do you wear his underwear does he
wear your indoor whatever is available
both yeah we've gone both ways we sure
clothing we share a lot of things he
doesn't work on really gran she does
like a boxer stuff like that so you just
you just look like a like a 1980s
wrestler then with her underwear huh all
colorful oh [ __ ] hey if it's comfortable
good idea
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]